qualche volta
no
contiene quella frase che ha cambiato in
maniera importante il mio modo di
lavorare
non si tratta solo di progettare
tecnologie
bisogna essere consci che quelle
tecnologie cambieranno la vita delle
persone a cui sono destinate anche se le
persone non la useranno paradossalmente
perché forse saranno arrabbiate o
frustrate da una tecnologia che magari
gli è stata imposta
durante i miei studi di ingegneria stavo
frequentando il corso di ingegneria del
software e la prima lezione del docente
entrando disse con la sua prima slide 90
per cento degli investimenti che si
fanno in tecnologia in particolare in
tecnologia informatica non portano
spesso ai frutti desiderati
non andiamo sindacare sul 90 per cento
piuttosto che 92 insomma questo numero
evidentemente un po alla volta si
abbassa ma mi dicono che non sia ancora
sceso sotto l'ottanta per cento
ero al terzo anno avevo due scelte la
prima era quella di lasciar perdere e
cambiare lavoro
la seconda invece quella di rendersi
conto che forse c'era tanto da fare e ho
deciso di andare fino in fondo su questa
faccenda della difficoltà di portare la
tecnologia alle persone perché ne
migliori la qualità della vita a quei
tempi assistevamo all'avvento della
programmazione orientata agli oggetti e
la programmazione orientata agli oggetti
aveva questo almeno è stata la mia
interpretazione tra le tante valenze la
possibilità di aiutare noi tecnici a
sviluppare delle tecnologie più
malleabili rispetto a quello che si
sviluppavano prima la malleabilità delle
tecnologie ha un impatto importante
quando le si porta nei contesti
lavorativi perché la tecnologia
evidentemente un po come un virus cambia
un organismo quindi cambia
un'organizzazione allora è complicato
approcciare facendo l'analisi dei
problemi inizialmente interpretando e
progettando una soluzione per portarla
perché i giochi cominciano nel momento
in cui la tecnologia entra in uso quello
è il momento in cui le persone vi danno
senso alla tecnologia allora insomma da
quella da quell'esperienza dieci anni fa
mi ero portato via
sicuramente la valenza dell'oggetto
oriente per creare tecnologie più più
flessibili però mi ero anche portato via
che forse quella cosa non bastava
qualche anno dopo infatti ragionammo e
pubblicando un articolo dedicato alla
progettazione delle tecnologie che
potessero essere ridefinita in uso
direttamente da parte di coloro che le
usano
era il 2002 a dir la verità questo
rimase un'intuizione per parecchi mesi
parecchi anni direi abbiamo dovuto
aspettare l'avvento di queste tecnologie
per cominciare a capire che quello
quella intuizione erano interdizione
interessante perché queste sono
effettivamente tecnologie che le persone
possono ridefinire in uso mentre le
usano
ed evidentemente questo è un processo il
divertimento di trovare delle
funzionalità che non c'erano ieri ma che
ci sono da oggi e di poterle portare su
questi dispositivi fa e fa parte di
quella che è l'esperienza delle persone
quando utilizzano la tecnologia e di
sicuro queste tecnologie sono tra quelle
che hanno impattato più di altre sulla
qualità della nostra vita
non ci penso un brano di dubbio quindi
avere tecnologie malleabili provare a
mettere nelle mani delle persone la
possibilità di ri configurarle queste
tecnologie
e allora è venuta la voglia di chiedersi
cos'altro si può fare per migliorare il
fatto che le persone comprendano portino
dentro di sé
la tecnologia è il terzo passaggio su
cui sto lavorando ed è un lavoro lungo è
quello di provare a far coincidere gli
utenti delle tecnologie conchiglie
progetta io penso che molta molto
dell'insuccesso legato all'introduzione
delle tecnologie nei contesti di lavoro
e di vita delle persone sia legato al
fatto che spesso chi le progetti alle
tecnologie non coincide con chi le usa e
il fatto di comprendere da tecnico il
contesto di vita e di lavoro degli altri
è un lavoro che anche sforzandosi con
empatia è una cosa molto complicata da
fare la tv tour i filosofi dicono che
non si può fare è inaccessibile la
conoscenza che stanno i contesti di vita
di lavoro degli altri anche se ci si
sforza di guardarli con occhi diversi
lì si va ad impattare su di un mondo che
non ci appartiene come tecnici
devo aggiungere anche il fatto che la
comprensione porta dentro una cosa nuova
che cambia il contesto quindi è una
comprensione che diventa piene rotonda
nella misura in cui effettivamente quel
contesto si riesce a viverlo i miei
colleghi che da ogni tanto mi mi
prendono in giro quando sentono che sono
particolarmente attaccato le vicende di
apple mi dicono assai un apple fan ma
non si tratta tanto di essere un apple
fan che quel mondo la un mondo che è
fatto di persone dove chi fa le
tecnologie spesso coincide con chi le
usa il mondo degli sviluppatori delle
app
se andiamo a vedere le app di maggior
successo troviamo quasi sempre una
corrispondenza importante tra chi con le
tecnologie le fa e che poi ne diventa
anche il primo utente questa per me è
una cosa cosmica insomma una cosa che mi
mi incuriosisce tantissimo il terzo
tassello questo tassello del avvicinare
le persone alla progettazione a che fare
con un'esperienza di progetto vissuta 78
anni fa
di cui gli effetti sono tuttora in campo
insomma li vivo tuttora tu sulla sulla
mia pelle a certe cose le ho capite
molto molto tardi dovevo affrontare una
consulenza in un'azienda particolarmente
complessa e mi ero portato per prendere
degli appunti questa tecnologia
meravigliosa che vedete qua le mie
spalle
io pensavo di utilizzarli per diciamo
velocizzare appunto la presa delle note
ma all'improvviso queste tecnologie sono
finite nelle mani delle persone che
avevo con me e che stavo per diciamo per
aiutare una consulenza di tipo
tradizionale all'improvviso boom
mi sono trovato catapultato
completamente fuori da questa esperienza
mentre li vedevo a loro agio utilizzare
questi materiali chiaramente accessibili
per loro si tratta di materiali semplici
insomma la carta i post it e alcuni
elementi di interfaccia e mi sono
meravigliato di quanta energia di quanta
creatività sia venuta fuori da quel
contesto di lavoro
ragionandoci poi dopo mi sono anche reso
conto che mai avrei potuto portare via
così tanto da loro anche in termini
proprio di relazione umana se non gli
avesse messi nella condizione di
cambiare le loro prospettive anche
cambiare la loro comprensione del
problema per avvicinarsi un po alla
volta da soli alle possibili soluzioni
soluzioni che non sono di natura
tecnologica soluzioni che questo è il
valore più importante includono loro
come utenti soluzioni dove loro per
primi possono sperimentare ma non
sperimentano la tecnologia sperimentano
quelle che sono le loro pratiche di
lavoro nuove per via della tecnologia
evidentemente sono tutti concentrati
sulle nuove pratiche di lavoro di
tecnologia non parlano
semplicemente sanno che prima o poi la
potranno avere a disposizione per
utilizzarla e qui il nodo centrale di
quello che sto facendo in questo momento
nella vita
qui si ridefinisce il concetto di design
di progettazione è una progettazione che
non porta più soluzioni con la pretesa
che siano giuste ma è una progettazione
che porta un linguaggio e protegge uno
spazio di lavoro all'interno del quale i
destinatari
quindi gli esperti quelli che hanno la
vera conoscenza di un contesto di lavoro
possono lavorare per innovare voglio
farvi sentire per ultima cosa una
brevissima intervista che ho fatto
qualche tempo fa ad un gruppo di queste
persone che sono diventate designer
dell'innovazione nella propria realtà
aziendale che ancora oggi portano avanti
il progetto
l'aspetto più importante di questo
laboratorio è la possibilità di lavorare
assieme un gruppo di lavoro
che non si costituisce
normalmente nel lavoro di tutti i giorni
e quindi di mettere in comune esperienze
diverse approcci diversi
i problemi a fare
nel tempo da scambiare le idee perché
appunto tante volte le idee c'è
ognuno ha le proprie però sentendo anche
le attenzioni nel senso che mi sentivo
portato è interessato è quello delle
funzioni di cui mi occupo di debiti
soprattutto al linguaggio web
però mi sono accorto che partecipare a
questo corso significa rimettere in
discussione e ripensare radicalmente
l'organizzazione del lavoro il nostro e
vedere anche sotto una nuova luce ok
quando oggi mi chiedono di parlare di
tecnologie dico sempre provocatoriamente
la tecnologia non esiste esiste quello
che provo provano le persone quando la
usano la tecnologia la mia storia mi sta
spostando da essere progettista di
tecnologie ad essere progettista della
comprensione delle tecnologie
io penso che avere le persone e la loro
energia e la loro intelligenza in un
contesto di progettazione che anche un
processo di apprendimento per loro sia
una cosa fondamentale oggi per avere
successo nel realizzare qualcosa che
impatti nella qualità della vita questo
evidentemente ridefinisce in maniera
importante anche il ruolo dell'esperto
delle tecnologie che non fa solo lo
human computer interaction ma fa lo
human to human interaction molto spesso
queste esperienze progettuali hanno
radicalmente cambiato il nostro sguardo
al design e abbiamo lavorato per una
decina d'anni su tutti di 100 progetti
con questi approcci e abbiamo costruito
un gruppo di persone alcune di queste
sono in questa sala e le ringrazio che
tutti i giorni portano avanti questa
visione dell'innovazione dedicandosi
grazie